Let's consider an example for max-min fair
allocation. Let's suppose that we have a link
with capacity ten and four demands. 2, 2.6, 4, and 5. Now, obviously the demands
exceed capacity. So we need to figure out a way of allocating rates to each of
these demands that is max-min fair. First, note that 10 divided by 4 is 2.5.
But this is not a good solution, because
the first user only needs 2. So the first
user would have an excess of .5 under
this allocation. So what we want to do is take
this excess of .5 and divide it among
the remaining 3 users, whose demands have not yet
been fulfilled. This would yield an allocation of
2, 2.67, 2.67 and 2.67. But now user 2
has an excess of 0.07, so we take that excess, divide it among
the remaining 2, and that gives us our final maximum fair allocation. Note that
this is called maximum fairness, because it
maximizes the minimum share to each user
whose demand is not fully serviced. In this case, the 3rd and 4th users.